you recently voiced a character on The
Simpsons I did yes I've done it twice
now that's great it's a huge deal yeah
and it's you know I've been a fan of the
show since you were writing on that show
way back when and not that long ago I'm
in my late 20s
you started in infancy exactly no yeah I
was there a long time ago but yeah
they're still going still going strong
and the shows are still really young and
so I was asked to do and it's always
this you know of course I would love to
and you show up and it's like the
basement of this horrible little
building and this I know that basement
really what you do yes I do
and the snacks are subpar it's not it's
not wait a bit wait what is it first of
all I believe that because yeah when I
was there Fox was cutting corners left
and right well they still are still are
when you talk about a subpar snack
you're going there you're gonna lend
your voice to the Simpsons this is a
hallowed moment yeah they're kind of
snacks are we talking it should be fully
catered it should be really good should
be really nice I mean it's been on the
air for how long how much money is
everybody generated a ton of money
yeah general and and everybody on it is
making a ton of money Here I am doing it
for freakin scale yeah and we candy is
like it's candy it's like Halloween
candy it's like bite size Snickers bite
size not even we don't get the full size
under low bar no you know I bet I bet
somewhere they bought full-size Snickers
and someone at Fox cut him in half
and sealed each end yeah licked it shut
and put it down but the actual the
actual voicing of the character was so
much fun and they had a beautiful like
rendering of kid the character I was
playing and it was just yeah I bet you
had an overbite everybody when they're
shown their character short cheese yeah
exactly that sometimes everybody and
yellow speaking of a great TV yeah that
just goes with it I don't know why
everyone in Springfield has a liver
disease